la policía metropolitana de londres
tendrá nuevo jefe cressida dic de 60
años la primera mujer en dirigir la
fuerza policial de la capital inglesa en
sus 193 años de existencia renunció este
jueves por encauzar suerte y marc
hablando en today
después del contacto con el alcalde de
londres está bastante claro que él ya no
tiene suficiente confianza en mi
liderazgo en el servicio de policía
metropolitana para que continúe como
comisionada
no me ha dejado más remedio que dar un
paso al costado digo esto con profunda
tristeza y lamentos with type sense and
the great big es además la primera
persona abiertamente homosexual en haber
accedido a tan alto rango había sido
nombrada dama por la reina isabel
segunda en los últimos años la confianza
en la policía metropolitana de londres
se ha visto sacudida por revelaciones
que incluyen el secuestro la violación y
el asesinato de sara everard una inglesa
de 33 años por parte de uno de sus
agentes hechos que ocurrieron en marzo
de 2021 además en febrero el organismo
de control de policía reveló una serie
de mensajes de whatsapp entre 14 agentes
de una comisaría londinense enviados
entre 2016 y 2018 que revelaban casos de
acoso sexual y laboral misoginia y
discriminación las respuestas dedicadas
de esta crisis dejaron insatisfecho al
alcalde los freak email
néstor son chris christie la semana
pasada le dejé claro a la comisionada de
la policía metropolitana
el cambio que creo que se requiere con
urgencia para reconstruir la confianza
de los londinenses en la policía y para
erradicar el racismo
el sexismo la homofobia la intimidación
la discriminación y la misoginia que aún
existe por ahora no se ha anunciado
quién la sucederá en el cargo pero quien
llegue tendrá de entrada el reto de
asumir las investigaciones de las
fiestas organizadas en downing street
durante los confinamientos por la
pandemia y en las que participó el
primer ministro boris johnson